Hello again movie fans. We're back with another
challenging quiz for you to test your cinematic
knowledge on - and this time, it has a special
theme.
Coming up are ten questions about some of
the most well-known Disney movies - both modern
and classic - and only true Disney fans will
be able to get full marks! Keep your score
as you go along and then leave it in the comment
section below! Make sure you tell the truth
though, or we'll rain down hell on you like
a classic Disney villain!This is the latest
instalment of Screen Rant's Ultimate Movie
Quiz series - the Disney Edition.
Fantasia
Fantasia remains one of Disney's most iconic
and successful movies to date but, upon its
original release, not only was it critically
panned, it was also unable to make any kind
of financial profit. What is the reason behind
this?
A - Parents deemed it too scary for their
children
B - World War II cut off its distribution
to the European market
C - Walt Disney himself hated it and pulled
it for some major tweaking
Due to the film's high production costs, and
the expense of leasing theatres and installing
the Fantasound equipment for the roadshow
presentations, Fantasia was unable to make
a profit without being distributed in Europe.
Unfortunately, upon its initial release, the
war prevented that from happening and it was
a commercial failure.
Song of the South
The controversial (and now banned) Disney
movie, Song of South, was based on the popular
African-American folk tales of Uncle Remus.
James Baskett starred as the character in
the movie, but why couldn't he attend its
premiere?
A - He was ill due to complications related
to diabetes
B - He was getting married
C - It was in Atlanta, which was racially
segregated by law
Shockingly, the movie's main star, James Baskett,
wasn't even allowed to attend the premiere
in Atlanta, Georgia, because he was black!
No hotel in the city would give him a room
because of the racial segregation laws that
were in practise at the time.
The Sword in the Stone
The Sword in the Stone is a Disney movie based
around Arthurian legend and features characters
from said legend like King Arthur, Merlin
and Sir Ector. But the character of Arthur
in the movie was weirdly inconsistent throughout.
In what way was this the case?
A - A number of different artists drew him,
making his appearance change throughout
B - More than one voice actor portrayed him
in the movie
C - The colour of his hair kept changing
Arthur was actually voiced by three different
young actors in the movie - Rickie Sorensen,
Richard Reitherman and Robert Reitherman.
The changes are extremely noticeable, as Arthur's
voice keeps alternating from being broken
to unbroken, sometimes in the same scene.
Bedknobs and Broomsticks
In Bedknobs and Broomsticks, the character
of Carrie - played by Cindy O'Callaghan - admires
a selection of dolls in the nursery of Professor
Brown's house. What were some of these dolls
modelled after?
A - Barbie and her friends
B - The puppets in Disney's "Small World"
ride
C - Russian nesting dolls
Several of the dolls that Carrie takes an
interest in, in the nursery of Professor Brown's
house, are modelled after the international
puppets in the Small World ride that can be
found at various Disney theme parks around
the world.
Robin Hood
In Disney's 1973 animated adaptation of Robin
Hood, the character of Friar Tuck - voiced
by Andy Devine - was depicted as a badger.
But what animal was the character originally
intended to be depicted as?
A - A pig
B - A mole
C - A rooster
Originally, the character of Friar Tuck in
this adaptation of Robin Hood was going to
be a pig, but it was changed to being a badger
to avoid insulting certain religious sensibilities.
Pocahontas
Pocahontas featured an impressive voice cast
that included the likes of Irene Bedard, Mel
Gibson, Christian Bale, Billy Connolly and
Frank Welker. It also initially included an
actor who died in 1994, whose role sadly had
to be scrapped as a result. Which late actor
was that?
A - John Candy
B - Telly Savalas
C - Peter Cushing
The late, great John Candy had actually provided
a large amount of voice work for a turkey
character named "Redfeather", who would have
been Pocahontas' sidekick. However, after
his tragic death from a heart attack, the
role was scrapped.
Toy Story
In Disney Pixar's modern classic Toy Story,
the two main characters - Woody and Buzz Lightyear
- were inspired by director John Lasseter's
own childhood toys. But which specific toys
from his childhood were they inspired by?
A - A Jack-in-the-Box and Batman
B - A Bozo the Clown doll and Action Man
C - A Casper doll and G.I. Joe
Woody and Buzz Lightyear were actually inspired
by Lasseter's pull-string Casper doll and
his G.I. Joe figures. Once he grew out of
his Casper, he moved onto G.I. Joe, which
was a very flashy toy at the time of his childhood.
Frozen
During the early developmental stage of 2013's
Frozen, the character of Elsa was actually
meant to be the villain of the movie. When
that was still the case, do you know which
famous actress the design of Elsa was going
to be inspired by?
A - Glenn Close
B - Meryl Streep
C - Bette Midler
That's right - at the stage of Frozen's development
when Elsa was still meant to be the villain
of the film, the design of the character was
actually inspired by none other than Bette
Midler.
Finding Dory
Every major Disney and Pixar character has
their own official Facebook page, but Finding
Dory's main character - the titular Dory - has
the most "likes" out of any of them, thanks
to the movie's massive success. How many likes
does she actually have?
A - 15 million
B - 20 million
C - 25 million
With a whopping 25 million likes on her official
page, Dory is the most liked character on
Facebook from any Disney or Pixar film - which
is pretty impressive, considering the strong
competition she has.
Beauty and the Beast
2017's live action adaptation of Beauty and
the Beast will feature all the classic characters,
including Belle, the Beast and Gaston. But
it will also feature some new ones. Stanley
Tucci, for example, will play a talking grand
piano. What will his name be?
A - Cadenza
B - Timbre
C - Overture
Back in 2015, it was announced that the brilliant
Stanley Tucci would be playing Cadenza, a
grand piano, and an original character created
specifically for this new live action version
of Beauty and the Beast.
Thanks for watching and for taking part in
the Disney Edition of our Ultimate Movie Quiz.
Did you enjoy this video? How well did you
do with the questions? Leave your score in
the comment section below and don’t forget
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
like this one!